hello reject nation
it's Greg Alva here and I'm John
Humphrey that beer I'll say your name
for you Matt cheese she's here
Matt beer is visiting from China today
yes and he is a fellow patron ejective
ours
and he's been one of our top patrons one
of our most interactive patrons might I
add a very dedicated follower of the
channel and he's visiting today from
China
like I said yes yeah and I was like dude
you gotta come by you got to come on the
channel so here he is today don't we
look good in the flesh I mean you guys
look perfect just like watching the show
but it's like a 4dx experience oh no
what we must not be that famous I guess
not you know get nervous not really by
minor what are you anyway here has a
show every year is a YouTube channel as
well that movie guy all one word and he
actually has a show that's also a trivia
show on there as well let's see how much
trivia this guy actually knows put you
to the test hold your feet up to the
fire by doing a reaction to the first
two rounds of the Schmo Dawid Rachel the
crusher versing Sam Levine one of the
the Jewish soldiers from Gloria fresh
burgers all right Matt let's see if
you're worthy enough to have your own
trivia show it's the paper I wanted you
to be a very specific way on this
channel I'm trying whatever I can to
make you feel comfortable and it is not
working we're skipping past all the
awesome introductions and whatnot what
are you we're gonna watch the their
introduction into the match and then
we're gonna stop it after round two
because only late to the party gets to
do a full video reaction
apparently apparently apparently Hammond
take the love Kristian harloff he's
super douchey in person but off-camera
you kind of prefer that way juicing
first representing the nerves watch with
a record of three wins and avatar reruns
channel she has the hots for Chong crush
it crush it
[Music]
that's it's more insulting to charity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how's your reaction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right burning thing between my toes
oh the categories their strengths are
[Music]
questions and your first question comes
from the world of dramas dramas and your
question is Andrew Dominik directed Brad
Pitt and good McNary in which crime
softly John is right category a bet to
see sci-fi fantasy sci-fi who plays a
younger version of Agent K Josh Brolin
I'm the best one here John you suck I'm
just gonna wait for you but I knew it
was Josh Brolin sure loved it these are
animated movies and your question is
you'll find a diamond-like villain named
the Horned King in what is the animated
film what never know that one the Horned
King which is it's Fantasia
is what they they call yeah alright guys
question four is in the category of
directors directors who directed The
Hurt Locker and Bigelow big turkey
Jeremy Renner you're not answering well
you know I like to let people in after
first Wow next question is all yours
that's all you got step out even if I
know it I'm not gonna say it
Rachel Cushing do you know who directed
those movies great of three after four
questions and now we go to action oh
that's my special section being named
one of the three challenges and the Last
Crusade will be a little live with our
answers yeah of course I have to answer
the one I don't know
we go with that one yes to get an
erection before the timer goes to the
key to the Holy Grail something like
that yeah West upper Anderson what is
the name of Ernie Hudson's character in
1984
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is the name of Ernie Hudson's
character Paul Feig
pens down and we're gonna go to sample
be first wow it does the last name final
question you're eight in the first round
is in the category of Oscars Oscars for
which role did win but declined to
accept to play this is the semi-finals
you don't just get lucky and bounce your
way this deep in the tournament I think
that this score proves that right I've
seen Rachael and team have kind of warm
first rounds but then really turn around
in the second round so we'll see if
Santa can hold her off it's closely
stand before the game given her a lot of
credit which is just but not giving
himself enough credit was that it was
that a trick was that it wouldn't strike
himself out kind of play here because he
is up now we all know your team with
Rachel coaching it's like your name
dropping now okay a weekend together
I don't used to be friends we understand
that you have her phone number okay we
know that you guys are social you don't
the right
I do famous friends it's Rachel Cushing
and cobster his broad shoulders the
wheel and round who comes out and set
wheel can determine your fortune for
good or for bad
nervous Matt Mira thought I was gonna go
to spin at that what do you want to spin
you have a tension in your shoulders
comfortably uncomfortable right now well
I know it's her preferred choice and one
of your favorite directors I'm expecting
you know some answers I haven't seen a
latest movie ever seen BFG
I've only ten want Steven Spielberg
movie that's why what I feel confident
in this category
orphan yeah now it's the up tear a big
[ __ ] gun yeah yeah thanks [ __ ]
John for Indiana Jones dress apart steel
goes and move on to your next question
in the world of Spielberg movies and it
is in the film jaws what public holiday
fourth of July the island preparing for
when the shark attacks strength the
fourth of July to go next one is who
played Tom Hanks's second in charge
sergeant Horvath ah Saving Private Ryan
damn I know the whole cast I just don't
know wow he was a second in command but
you see he was his first name you came
on my that was my first question is with
Peter Pan was the name of the boy who
became their de facto leader Rufio
Rufio
yo yo that guys Filipino puts the
traction on since he goes for his whoa I
know my people in opponents choice it's
going to hit territory oh sure just um
us Hilbert and Fincher before we fill I
hope he goes come on Club Penguin
[Music]
Nicholas or David Fincher's wasn't
Michael Douglas see if I got count-out I
want to just guess my wife Tracy that is
correct for two more points to take a
lead take a lead all right who plays
Jodie Foster's 11 year old daughter Oh
Twilight chicken
[Music]
maybe Fisher's know my scripts that they
have seen everyone adventures but we're
not allowed to show the rest but you
know we'll do we're gonna watch the rest
and give you our reaction to the rest
without telling you who won in case you
haven't seen the match ah well I gotta
say the winners last question I thought
was way too easy name two performers who
have appeared at two or more and Paul
Thomas Anderson films Boogie Nights and
Magnolia have so many of the same
players and I don't know he uses the
same casts for laces a lot of the same
cast members for a lot of things I mean
even Daniel day-lewis is going out with
a it's a three-pointer wasn't a five
guys and Tanya man you gotta finish the
rest of this match there's the rest of
this message a harrowing match I feel
like when I do this game a lot of times
the faces come to my mind but the
pressure will delay the name it's like I
always get the name eventually but I'm
by myself I get it really fast like a
camera like here's rolling yeah
state yeah it's like an Owen I always
see the face like Julia Stiles name
wasn't coming to me right away or
Kristen Stewart's name wasn't coming
around I'm like I know it's the Twilight
girl it was like a to say like a
5-second to like just I would have to
use too many repeat the questions would
you ever want to compete in the showdown
I would but I don't think I would do
well necessary really I wouldn't go that
far
might win a couple games how come you
don't think you do well what will be
your strengths you think comic book
movies on sit Saverio but what's your
favorite comic book Logan Logan yeah
then okay that's interesting yeah so
it's not the Dark Knight
no that's not it's a really good movie
okay I know it's your patreon it's
really good Batman Begins more I mean
Heath Ledger's obviously fantastic and
can you feel the tension
it is palpable it's kinda well it's good
to meet you with a gun that's what we do
we kill people who have different
opinions it'd be like a good blow-up
doll sure and I'll take that yeah
why the first one who's had a positive
response to that comment because my
family did not respond love that guy
I make everybody happy in sense I would
say you make me happy it's cuz I'm here
below whoa don't say that with a crack
in your voice sorry sorry this is so
much fun
no girls ever comfortable I don't know I
don't know what to do about this Schmo
damn man I get nervous I feel like the
last couple times I played though I've
done really well you have but because
I'm next to this guy everyone's like you
gotta get a different team and no one
factors in how many points I've got in
each time you are a tremendous player
and on average you are probably more
solid than me except forever like those
one time he's MVP because it's free for
everyone says in the comments you you do
you pleasure me as my blow-up doll sure
yeah you do you're the first live
blow-up doll I've ever had that's the
goal cuz I have like ten unblown of
dolls that I've given it John there's
gonna be a movie about this in the
counter someday wouldn't wouldn't blow
up sex robots are yeah so sentient and
it's gonna be a weird a nice dragon the
real boy we're instead of you know Ryan
Gosling try to convince people this
blow-up doll is real I'm trying to
convince people that Matt beers a
blow-up doll anyway subscribe buttons
exist click that notification valve
check out Collider videos for more
good day people peace